though whether it is bad in a lot of
places a deadly winter storm is hitting
millions of Americans as we start this
last full week before Christmas it's
bringing snow and ice and rain to a
1,600 mile stretch of the country parts
of Missouri saw whiteout over the
weekend nearly 12 inches of snow fell
rather near Kansas City and a 24-hour
period
winter weather alerts are up from
Colorado to Massachusetts CBS News
climate and weather contributor Geoff
Barrow Delhi is tracking the chaos and
the trouble on the roads a powerful
winter storm is wreaking havoc across
the central u.s. in Missouri the snow
left dozens of drivers stranded the
Kansas City Fire Department said they
responded to at least 40 crashes in just
three hours in Illinois heavy snow
caused a car to slide onto railroad
tracks where it was hit by a freight
train the drivers somehow walking away
with no major injuries in Nebraska five
people died in two separate crashes on
Interstate 80 on Sunday in some cases
roads were closed for hours it's
definitely going to be weather-related
slick surfaces farther west in you Tom a
snowboarder died after an avalanche in
the backcountry authorities are now
warning of a high early season avalanche
danger following the first fatality of
the season and Jeff bardelli is with us
Jeff where is this storm heading good
morning Anthony it is heading towards
the east and it's going to be with us at
least another 36 hours there's the wide
view future radar later today we could
see moderate to heavy snow st. Louis all
the way to Indianapolis and approaching
Pittsburgh later tonight some of that
snow could move into places like New
York City and Scranton but quickly
followed by rain as milder air moves in
Philly New York all the way up to
Hartford where there will be ice but
look at tomorrow morning in Boston
Scranton in Albany it is snow turns to
rain across most of the coastal areas as
we head through the day tomorrow ice is
a problem this morning south of st.
Louis and overnight and tomorrow in
places like Pennsylvania in New York as
far as snowfall goes there will be a
swath of 2:00 to 4:00 some places
picking up greater than six inches of
snow especially as we head into the
upstate of New York and severe weather
is also a problem in the southeast could
see some isolated tornadoes today and
guys right here in New York City we
don't get
25 degrees on Thursday almost white
Christmas time though Jeff thank you
very much